all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy podcast has
bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast for we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist ever gonna talk about
several modern crises we're gonna talk
about depression loneliness addiction
connection belonging and meaning with
today's guests Johann Hari is here after
the fourth introduction we finally got
his name right yeah so yo-yo hand thank
you for joining us today man I want to
talk about both your books - books
chasing the screen you have lost
connections as your newest book we're
gonna get into those but this is a
listener driven show so I thought maybe
we could start with some questions our
first our first question today is from
Brian in Connecticut hi guys my name is
Brian Kelsey and I'm from Colchester
Connecticut I've been searching for a
way become more happier but at the same
time more fulfilled and live a life of
meaning and being around people and
positive influence like my family and
friends I was actually recommended this
podcast by somebody I trust and I found
myself not being able to stop listening
enough spend most of my time listening
to this podcast more than being trapped
in the Bermuda Triangle of social media
apps like Instagram snapchat and
Facebook and being more cognitive and
aware of what I'm doing I was wondering
what you would recommend 20 year olds
like myself and wish to continue
enhancing my life and working towards a
meaningful lifestyle alright so so your
hand the first thing I thought about was
something from your most recent book
lost connections I'll hold it up here
for the folks watching on on YouTube so
I think it's page 88 you talk about well
we check our phones every six minutes
mm-hmm so that's a sort of pacifier
right 42% of us never turn off our phone
which is a red flag but then there is
this quick passage here I thought a lot
about this about the depression or
anxiety preceded that preceded the
compulsive internet used for everyone
here so everyone here the context of
this is you are at a sort of rehab for
video gamers was that right well it's a
it's interesting cuz the the crisis
you'll call a the kind of problem that
led your call it to your podcast is in a
way the the the problem that led me to
do the to do go on this three-year
journey all over the world to try to get
the answers for my book because there
were these two mysteries that were
really hanging over me right the first
mystery is I'm 40 years old and all
throughout my life depression and
anxiety have increased here in the
United States and across the Western
world right year after year and I wanted
to understand well why right why is this
happening to so many of us why well
clearly we have a prozac deficiency when
I take the antidepressant or he could
come back to that question but the the
second mystery very related to what
you're saying is it was a more personal
one which is when I was a teenager so a
little bit younger than your call oh not
that much younger I remember going to my
doctor explaining that I had this
feeling like pain was leaking out of me
right I didn't understand it I had
exactly that kind of hollow feeling that
your caller has and my doctor told me a
story that I now realize wasn't totally
wrong but it was really oversimplified
and my doctor said well we know why
people get like this doctor so he said
some people just naturally have a
chemical imbalance in their brains just
happens to some people you're clearly
one of them all we need to do is give
you some drugs and you're going to be
fine and I started taking a chemical
antidepressant called paxil and I felt
significantly better at first but then
not long afterwards this feeling of pain
started to come back so I went back I
was given higher and higher doses until
for thirteen years I was taking the
maximum possible dose that you're
allowed to take and while I got some
relief I still essentially felt like
[ __ ] right and and at the end of it I
started myself well what's going on here
because according to the story our
culture is telling I'm doing everything
that you're meant to do and yeah it's
not
working for me so I ended up going on
this big journey all over the world I
travelled over 30,000 miles I wanted to
interview the the leading experts in the
world about what causes depression and
anxiety and people with very different
perspectives from you know an Amish
village in Indiana because the Amish
have very low levels of depression we
can talk about why I think it's very
related to a lot of your or your themes
to a lab in Baltimore where they're
giving people psychedelics to see if
that helped to a city in Brazil that
banned advertising to see if that would
make people feel better and I learned
star power
exactly and I learned a massive amount
but the core of what I learned is
there's scientific evidence for nine
different causes of depression anxiety
that we know about so far there'll be
others we don't know about yeah two of
them are indeed in our biology it's
important to talk about them and I'm
sure we will but most of the factors
that cause depression and anxiety aren't
not in our biology they're factors in
the way we live and once you understand
them that opens up a very different set
of solutions and I think but I think
this issue with with this caller I think
it's what I tell I'd start by talking
about one of these causes I think the
fact he's been drawn to your podcast
suggests to me this might be one that
that would connect with him although
maybe it wouldn't and there clearly many
others that we can get to so and I found
this I found this quite challenging for
several reasons so everyone knows junk
food has taken over our diets and
Meadows physically sick right I don't
say this with any sense of superiority
one of the great low points of my life
was on on Christmas Eve 2009 I went to
my local KFC at lunchtime in East London
and Anna and I went in so it was so
awful the guy the guy behind the counter
I said my standard order which is so
disgusting I'm not gonna repeat it to
you and the guy behind the counter said
oh yeah and I'm really glad you're here
wait a minute and he went off behind
where they fried the chicken and
everything and he came back with the
other staff member who was on and a
[ __ ] massive Christmas card in which
they'd written to our best customer and
everyone who worked in this case he had
written like personal messages to me
with little enjoye and my clogged heart
sank and I was like Jesus this is I have
to
humming it anyway actually that card was
the single greatest weight loss device
I've ever had in my life but and I
remember the line in the book is
materialism this KFC for the Soul
exactly
just like junk food has taken over our
diets and made us physically sick a kind
of junk values have taken over our minds
and made us mentally sick so for
thousands of years philosophers have
said if you think life is about money
and status and possessions you're gonna
feel like [ __ ] right that's not an exact
quote from shoppin Howard but that is
the gist stories that right I believe
that was Seneca yeah weirdly nobody had
actually scientifically investigated
this until a guy you guys should totally
talk with an incredible man named
Professor Tim caso who's at Knox College
in Illinois who I spent a lot of time
interviewing and and went see um and
professor Casa we began this research
about about about 25 years ago and it
was it was already known at that time
the human beings have basically two
kinds of motivation you can divide our
motives into two types and every one is
a mixture of both right so there are
what best way to explain it
imagine you play the piano if you play
the piano in the morning because you
love it and it gives you joy that's
what's called an intrinsic motive to
play the piano right you're not doing it
to get anything out of it you're doing
it because that moment is meaningful to
you you love it right
I can now imagine you play the piano not
because you love it but I don't know in
a dive bar that you hate to pay the rent
or because your parents are massively
pressuring you hmm
you know because that's their dream or a
no to post the clips on Instagram to get
likes right that would be and what's
called an extrinsic reason to play the
piano you're not doing it because that
experience gives you joy you're doing it
to get something out of it further down
the line and obviously to be a human
being you've got to be both right sure
obviously but professor Casas research
discovered loads of really interesting
things about this firstly well I mean
the most important is he showed that the
more your life is dominated by these
extrinsic values by doing things not
because they're
meaningful to you but to get something
out of it like money or status or likes
and the more likely you are to become
depressed and anxious I really quite
significant amount right I know why yeah
so there's there's many reasons and it's
why I don't draw that analogy with junk
food right just like junk food that
everyone needs food and everyone needs a
value system to guide them through life
and just like junk food appeals to the
parts of us evolve that to need food a
nutrition but actually hijacks that
poisons ours makes us fat and sick and
in a similar way these extrinsic values
which I think are analogous to junk food
if they go too far there are kind of
junk I call them junka values if they
dominate they appeal to the part of us
that are looking for guides through life
and yet they hijack that part of us and
actually takers they train us to seek
happiness in all the wrong places and
there's there's many reasons why why
extrinsic values living in a way that's
dominated by junk values make us feel so
bad and professor castle goes through
many examples that I give in in in in
the book give you an example of one this
might sound like a bit of a cheap thing
to say I don't mean it as a cheap dig at
this person so in 2009 Melania Trump
went to speak at NYU I quite imagine why
it was before the political thing and a
student asked her would you have married
Donald Trump if he wasn't rich and she
said do you think he would have married
me if I wasn't beautiful hmm there you
can see what that reveals about the
nature of a relationship that's
dominated by junk valleys what does it
reveal Melania Trump knows if she got
fat if she lost her looks in some other
way she'd be out and Donald Trump knows
if he lost his money and status and
power his wife would be out the door
right now the Trump's are a very extreme
example for all sorts of obvious reasons
but we've all become more like the
Trump's so one of the other things Tim
caster showed that's really important is
that as a society as a culture
all throughout I think we're all about
the same age all throughout our
lifetimes
we've become much more driven by these
extrinsic junk values they've got year
after year after year under the weight
of advertising and Instagram and
everything like them so there are many
reasons why extrinsic values make us
feel worse so one is they make your
relationships more insecure more
contingent on on things you can see how
that would make you less happy
another example is related to I think a
deeper and more important thing which is
everyone knows that they have natural
physical needs obviously you need food
you need water you need shelter you need
clean air if I took those things away
from you you you both be in real trouble
real fast yeah but there's equally
strong evidence that all human beings
have natural psychological needs you
need to feel you belong you need to feel
your life has meaning and purpose you
need feel that people see you and value
you if you've got a future that makes
sense and this culture we built is good
at lots of things I'm glad to be alive
today but we've been getting less and
less good at meeting these deep
underlying psychological needs and one
of the problems with these junk values
is they don't meet your deeper needs it
you know you don't feel you belong just
because you've got a thousand retweets
you don't feel seen and valued because
you've got loads of money in the bank
right you don't feel your life has
meaning and purpose because someone
famous tweeted about you right so what
what what junk values do and we you know
we live in a machinery from the moment
we're born that gets us to structure our
lives by chasing these junk values right
I mean and more 18 month old children in
the United States know what the
McDonald's M means they know their own
last name so from the moment you're born
you are immersed in this machinery right
T trains you if you don't feel good
we've got a solution for that treat
yourself go shopping buy stuff that's
that's the primary script we're given
but how to feel better we're trained to
interpret our behavior and think about
our goals in this way and that leads us
in a path you know in some ways it's
quite challenging remember talking to
press a casa and
it's a cliche to say to people right
none of your going to lie on your
deathbed and think about all the likes
you got on Instagram and all the shoes
you bought right you're going to think
about moments of love and meaning and
connection in your life and I thought
isn't this almost banal but then
professor caso said to me yeah some
level we know these things but as he put
it to me we live in a machine that is
designed to get us to neglect what is
important about life I had to really
think about that we live in a machine
that's designed to get us to neglect
what's important about life and and so
we have this strange conflict where at
some level we know these insights we
know them to the point where they're up
in our cliches and yeah we live in a
machine that gets us to live in a very
different very different way so the
rediscovery of those intrinsic values is
the single most important thing I would
recommend to your caller think about and
professor Kassar did a really
interesting experiment with a wonderful
guy named Nathan dung in exactly about
this it's really simple I really urge
people now there's lots of big
structural things we need to do to deal
with junk values like massively regulate
advertising I would actually ban a lot
of appetizers and lots of things we can
do talk about the structural things but
in terms of advice for this and I would
urge this individual caller to fight for
that but I would have talked about
things that he can do in his own life a
more individual level or group level so
professor Catherine and Nathan Duncan
did this really interesting experiment
your caller can can try him self so and
it began because Nathan Duncan is a
financial advisor in Minneapolis so his
job is to advise people on budgeting
like probably person or house or
budgeting and he got a call from a
school it's a kind of middle class
school it's not fancy but it's not poor
and they said will you come in because
we've got a real problem here we our
kids are teenagers are teenagers our
teenagers are just demanding really
expensive consumer goods like Nike
sneakers or the latest iPhone and if
they don't get it they go apeshit right
and their parents often can't afford
it's causing a load of stress and hassle
at the school and with the at the home
could you come in and explain budgeting
to these kids right he comes in and does
his normal thing which is explaining
budgeting and
quite quickly he realizes these kids
don't give a [ __ ] about budgeting
something else is going on here right so
he then teamed up with with Professor
Casa to do this experiment to see if
they could deal with the underlying
problem which was precisely these kids
have been primed to think they needed
things that no some you know that no
sensible person needs so it's real
simple experiment what they did is they
they get teenagers and their parents to
come to groups over a period of months
and the first session they just asked
them they say to the good piece of paper
and they say discuss this with your
family we want you to write down things
you've got to have right now just what
you got to have not things what you got
to have right and and so obviously
everyone at first puts things like
shelter food like something mm-hmm but
quite quickly
hey what I need Nike sneakers right now
the parents ago I need certain name some
fancy car or whatever and and then they
the people leading the group would say
okay well let's talk about how your life
would be different if you've got these
things how would you feel why do you
want them and and interestingly very few
people named the actual like function of
the thing they wanted right so the
people who wanted Nike sneakers didn't
say oh I'm a basketball player and I
want to be able to jump higher there
people who wanted the fast car didn't go
oh I'm a surgeon I need to be able to
get really quickly to the hospital right
they said things like people will envy
me I'll feel I belong right these were
and this wasn't some buried insight it
was the first thing people said mmm-hmm
it doesn't take long to get people to
say that out loud before you go why do
you think having a little is it blue
blue tick on your sneakers is gonna mean
that your person who deserves to belong
and be recognized
right you begin to pick that apart
everyone likes to think they're smarter
than advertising but you realize these
impressions have been invented by
advertising they've been created by a
very sophisticated machinery to make you
think you'll have that feeling if you
get this object of course you don't
we've all had that experience of buying
something expensive a brief rush you get
home and then you feel like [ __ ] again
right yeah and so in
surely it was about deconstructing those
junk values and then more importantly it
because if you take away someone's
better you've got to give them a better
value system right
meaning what value exactly going to
activate the more meaningful values in
their life they already have them at
some level everyone does but the so then
they would have sessions where they talk
about okay let's talk about moments when
you have actually experience meaning
connection in your life and everyone can
think of something and lots people know
different things some people it was you
know playing music running writing
taking their kids to the beach a whole
range of things and and the group was
designed to get people to ask okay
how could you build more of your life
around pursuing these meaningful values
and less around chasing these junk
values and just having these
conversations we don't I mean your
percuss is a great example of this these
conversations we don't have these
conversations very often in this culture
just checking in and having these
conversations a bit like a kind of
Alcoholics Anonymous for consumerism and
led to a measurable and significant
shift in people's values away from these
depression generating junk values to
more meaningful values so what I would
recommend to your caller and colchester
is get a group it is very hard to do
this on your own as an isolated
individual get a group of your friends
together have these meetings once agreed
to weeks once a month talk about the
things you actually find meaningful in
your lives talk about the temptation of
junk values because that temptation is
there for all of us right in this
culture you are being you know invaded
by those messages all the time yeah we
Ryan I often call them imaginary value
so we donate as four types of values
people want to go back listen to episode
68 or 69 about values and where we dive
deep in the four different types of
values that we often talk about and
there are these imaginary values where
you would call junk values and then
they're like minor values and I think
quite often we get confused and it's
turned upside down where it is the Nikes
are gonna make me
and make other people envy me or it's
going to be the you know back in my
corporate days I had to Lexus's like
well why was one Lexus not enough
by the way alexis is just a fancy Toyota
anyway was a Toyota not enough Ryan I
just had a conversation with people
judge about yeah I see nice in the flesh
oh he's great he's a really good dude
genuine dude anyway we were talking to
him Ryan are from Dayton Ohio which in
2017 was the overdose capital of America
you know fifty thousand overdoses that
year many many deaths as well and heat
the thing he talked about is you know
there's a crisis of belonging there it's
funny I feel like he was quoting you
like when we were interviewing him
people have said to me that I think him
I'm Mary I'm William some have read my
book because they keep saying things
that are very similar but it's great
like you're influencing some people who
who need to be influenced in this win
had kind of had that perspective I would
like to touch on that crisis of
belonging but for the sake of this
segment I'm gonna move on real quick
Brian I am going to send you a copy of
lost connections we're gonna send you
copy that I think you'll find a lot of
value let me say this real quick yo hand
this is a beautifully written book and
you were very talented writer I'm I
teach a writing class and this is
something that I'm going to be talking
to students about in terms of creating a
moving a narrative forward and so Bravo
you you've you've created a beautiful
book I'm also about halfway through
chasing the screen as well so I'm gonna
recommend that to folks as well but uh
branagh missin you copy this I'm also
going to send you a copy of Ryan's in my
book essential it's an essay collection
and there's a technology chapter in here
about using technology more deliberately
there's so we could talk about tech if
you want that because it was implicit in
his question yeah I think so we will be
diving into tech in fact we've got a few
questions about well I think we I think
we're gonna unpack Brian's question for
another hour but I think the key
takeaways for Brian are is is get clear
on what your true values values are in
your short term actions need to align
with those those long term values and
make sure those values are are
meaningful and that's what creates a
meaningful life and the only thing I'll
add to that is when you strive to live a
meaningful life happiness is this
beautiful by-product you don't
the chase happiness it will it will
happen so start there Brian and yeah
will certainly cover more of it entirely
right that we have this flawed
conception of happiness in this culture
I think it's flawed in several ways so
the Greeks had to two out of two words
for happiness which have very different
meanings so we had had onea which is
like hedonism right which is like
partying that is that the happiness you
feel that a great party right when
you're dancing the dopamine release a
zalien and then there's eudaimonia which
is the happiness you feel when you're
doing something satisfying and
meaningful right and of course you
should have both in like I'm in favor of
partying sure but you domain EO is a
much more important and much more
sustainable form happy there's no one
can party all the time we've all had
friends who partied all the time and end
up being you know kind of rattled and
broken and miserable right yeah but you
die monia is a really important form
happiness pursuing meaning a meaning can
carry you through pain in a way that
hedonism can't right so I think we have
I think there's another the in terms of
how to very careful whenever I have a
slight sinus problem and because I wrote
a book about why we should legalize
drugs if I start rubbing my nose during
interviews it looks very very the yeah
another key mistake we make about
happiness is explained to me by a
brilliant academic called dr. Brett
forward based on her her research was it
Berkeley at the time and it this really
interesting research so want to figure
out if you try to make yourself happier
deliberately let's say one of your
listeners sitting there going I'm going
to spend an hour a day trying to make
myself happier would you actually become
happier and they studied this in four
countries the United States Taiwan
Russia and Japan and what they found it
first seems really weird in the United
States if you try to make yourself
happier you do not become happier on
average but in the other countries if
you try to make yourself become happier
you do it works and they're like why
would that be what's going on so they
did more work there were loads of teams
it wasn't just put forward looking at
this and what they figured out was and
of course they're exceptions but
generally in the United States if you
try to make yourself happier you do
something for yourself
you buy something you work harder you
try to get a promotion it's a self we
have a an individualistic conception of
happiness in the other countries and of
course they're exception so it's well
but in the main if you try to make
yourself happier you do something for
someone else your friends your family
your right
so they have an instinctively collective
idea what it means to be happy
contribution yeah slightly and it turns
out iron our dear happiness don't work
its materialism yeah its materialism and
it's self focused it's a morality to
there's all of these sort of junk values
yeah it's you you you talking about the
hedonism versus what was the other word
eudaimonia
yeah one is necessarily ephemeral it's
it's the momentary pleasure it's the you
know I you talk about you're struggling
with weight gain in your early twenties
all the same way I weighed 80 pounds
more than I weigh now and I just like a
child bruised so I you because you get
that yeah well Joe Rogan calls mouths
pleasure like you just get that moment
of like a hostage tastes so good right
and and whenever he says that I always
the only thing I picture is [ __ ]
alright our lightning round this is
where we answer questions with social
media we just you know we've got days to
prepare like short little tweetable
answers meaning you want me to answer
quickly yes okay exactly I'm not good at
brevity so you could write you can
ramble a little bit but uh try to keep
it short all right here we go our first
question is from April are the rates of
depression really as high as reported or
is it over diagnosed and used as a
crutch and I'm assuming she's talking
about the Western world here what what
do you think I think the problem with
that is it misunderstands what
depression is and so most people think
what I was taught by my doctor is your
depression is purely a problem in your
brain it's a purely a biological problem
and needs purely a biological solution
in fact all the scientific evidence and
this isn't some field science a fringe
science the World Health Organization
the leading medical body in the world
has been trying to tell us this for
years if that depression has
three kinds of cause biological causes
which are very real psychological causes
or two how you think about yourself and
social causes the way we live together
they are all real that all play out to
some degree in all forms of mental
illness so I think implicit in April's
question totally understandably this is
what you're told as a culture is the
real depression is stuff that's purely
biological and then there's this kind of
other stuff that might be social or
psychological actually a more sensible
way talking about it it's just pain and
distress right
are there loads of people in the society
with pain and distress that's a great
way of reframing it do you know what I
mean yeah and the other crucial
reframing I think is once you understand
this that it's a response to things like
unmet needs right like loneliness or
meaningless work you begin to see
depression very differently because the
way I was taught to think about my
depression was that it was a malfunction
right it's a like a glitch in a computer
program it's just a wiring problem in
your brain
in fact in almost all cases depression
is a signal mmm it's telling you such a
symptom exactly you feel this way for
reasons those reasons can be understood
and together we can fix them that's a
very different reframing so I think
there's I understand the point April's
making which is there are many problems
which are promoted by the pharmaceutical
industry and pathologized in order to
drug people right yeah and I think
implicit in what she's saying is well is
this being overhyped in order to sell
people drugs right now drugs give some
relief to some people we're happy to
talk about that if you want although
they're ultimately not solving the
problem for most of us as you can see in
there's loads of research on that so I
think there's an element of truth in
what she's saying which is we've been
oversold biological solutions yeah and
part of the problem with giving these
purely biological answers to this
problem telling people an entirely
biological story is that it tells them
and this isn't the intention of the
people saying it but what are implicitly
says to people is your pain doesn't mean
anything mmm right it's like a yeah it's
like a glitch in a computer program I
was only able to change my life and I
think we'll only be able to change this
culture that's causing this to brush
when we explain to people your pain
makes sense you feel this way for
reasons that are actually entirely
understandable in for which was very
good scientific evidence and to get and
the deepest solution is for us to fix
these problems together yeah isn't that
fast but always no no that was brief
comparatively briefest I ever get
alright Tabitha writes in how would you
recommend an introvert develop
connections and friendships I have no
friends and that isn't an exaggeration
unless of course you count my cat
Tabitha of course your cat counts yeah
25% of all Millennials in the United
States say they have no friends 40% of
Americans asked do you feel like no one
any longer no Z well so that describes
them so Tabitha you're not alone yeah
and it's kind of heartbreaking and what
I would argue and you shouldn't feel
ashamed of that you're very much not
alone I would argue for a structural
solution so wait that almost sounds like
an oxymoron like you're not alone in
being alone right this it's like you are
alone but you're not alone there's
something to see there's not a problem
yeah right right that you're that this
culture is making lots of people feel
this way yeah and there are many
solutions but I would recommend one and
it's one of the kind of heroes and my
book loss connections is a doctor named
Sam Everton he's a general practitioner
just not ordinary I'm doctor in East
London and Sam had a loads of patients
coming to him who were terribly
depressed and anxious like Tabitha and
very isolated and Sam like me isn't
opposed to chemical antidepressants and
thinks they have some value but he could
see firstly a lot of people who's giving
them too were remaining depressed and
secondly they weren't solving the
problem right for a lot of people not
for everyone
sure so one day Sam decided to try this
different approach that's now spreading
all over Europe and a woman came to see
him how I got to know later named Lisa
Cunningham and Lisa is a wonderful
person Lisa be shut away in her home
with you know just completely isolated
for seven years crippling depression and
anxiety she actually had cats as well so
but thought at least someone not seeing
Tabitha's messaging and and one day
which came to Sam's
suite of doctors offices
she was told don't worry I'll carry on
giving you these drugs I'm also going to
prescribe something else there was an
area behind the suite of doctors offices
that was just like scrubland they said
to Lisa okay what I'd like to do is come
in twice a week meet with a group of
other depressed and anxious people on
this scrubland and figure out something
you can do together we don't want you to
talk about how miserable you are you can
do that if you want but find something
meaningful to do together this isn't a
support group to talk about your pain
this is a group to do something good
right first time the group met Lisa
literally started vomiting with anxiety
because she liked habit that she'd been
so cut off for so long mmm but the group
starts talking and they're like okay
what could we do
these are inner-city East London people
like me they didn't know anything about
gardening they were like okay let's
learn gardening they took loads of books
at library they start watching YouTube
clips they started to get their fingers
in the soil they started to learn the
rhythms of the seasons there's a lot of
evidence that exposure to the natural
world is a really powerful
antidepressant but they start to do
something even more important they
started to form a group they started to
form a tribe they started to care about
each other the way Lisa put it to me as
the garden began to bloom we began to
bloom there was a study in Norway of a
very similar program that found it was
more than twice as effective as chemical
antidepressants I think one obvious
reason it was dealing with some of the
reasons why they felt so terrible in the
first place so why I would say to
Tabitha is look for firstly the rest of
us should get help - Tabitha by fighting
for a medical system that gives people
support and help like this yes so we
should be giving her the message help is
on the way but as that is happening I
would recommend looking at websites like
meetup and and and going to I think just
going into a bar or something when
you've been cut off for so long it's
just nice and probably Hollis but
meetup.com I totally agree like that's
and in fact that's what I kind of had
written down before it was like look
you're uncomfortable to go meet with
other people you have to go make
yourself uncomfortable and you can do
that by going to meetup.com and joining
groups and doing something that that
gets you out there making connections
exactly and I think that is a appreciate
how terribly painful that would be
Tabitha yeah but a life of connection is
a meaningful life absolutely and it is
worth taking that risk and the most
important thing is to remember that you
are surrounded by people who feel the
same way who are waiting
someone to be the person who puts up the
distress signal right yeah and I can
tell your story about that if you want
but it would be let's save it for the
maximal episode all right cool well we
got a bunch more to talk about today
before we get to our added value and
before we get to our right here right
now segment right we've got some really
good questions here how does our
obsession with material possessions make
us more anxious depressed and lonely and
what's the solution is social media the
main contributor to our modern anxiety
we're also gonna talk to Johan about
well we're gonna talk about gratitude
we're gonna talk about the overuse and
appropriate use of antidepressants we're
gonna talk about the continued increase
in suicide rates we're gonna talk about
the role of food in depression we're
gonna talk about how the drug crisis is
really a crisis of meaning and belonging
and we're going to talk about how
several countries have fixed their own
drug crises and so much more if you want
to hear all that you can listen to this
week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public Plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast to keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff over at the minimalists com slash
support Ryan what else you got for us
this week being informed is more
important than ever these days and you
at home you listening to this you can be
more informed by listening to Johann
Hari 's book lost connections it's a
great deep dive that I think you will
enjoy and also I've got some voicemail
tips and tricks from our listeners check
them out Josh hey Joshua and Ryan this
is Joe Rossi I'm from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania anyway I was calling him
because recently about two weeks ago I
actually had an opportunity to watch
your documentary after listening to it
get mentioned on another podcast that I
listened to and I was really enamored
with your message being very reluctant
initially to jump headfirst into the
minimalist lifestyle I really took an
inventory of what are the
things that are drawing me back from
living my life the way I wanted to and
really on the top of all of my lists and
in the back of my head I realized it was
my cell phone I don't think that using
cell phones are necessarily inherently a
problem but for me as a dad of 10 month
old twins anything that the distraction
from my kid is difficult because as you
can imagine we ripped through formula
and diapers and all kinds of toys and
fun things all the time and if I look
down even just for one second to check
Instagram notification or an email from
my boss or a text chain for my friends
something really amazing could be
happening like the first time that they
walked or kind of scary could be
happening like they're getting into
something that they shouldn't so I made
a decision to actually switch to a dumb
phone I contacted my wireless provider
and got my sim card shipped replaced and
now I just have a phone that only texts
t9 like it's 2001 and makes phone calls
and it really has that small amount of
minimalism really has made a big
difference in my life in fact I was
waiting in line and typically my nose
would be ferried by phone and I had an
opportunity to talk to a guy that was
behind me that had a really neat classic
truck that I saw pull into the parking
lot and ended up making a friend and
learning a little bit about the
mechanical parts of old trucks and stuff
so I wanted to call and say thank you
because I really appreciate it
hi my name is Cecilia Duffy from Geneva
Ohio I have a tip for minimizing and
organizing your tax records I am mostly
paperless with my taxes make a folder on
your computer with the tax year inside
that folder you'll make other files and
folders that will hold all your needed
receipts and either in Excel or Word
document with a list of the tax items by
date name and amount for instance my
2016 tax folder has the following number
1 a 2016 donation receipts folder I scan
all receipts here and throw away the
paper number 2 2016 medical receipts
folder again scan it receipts into here
and you can pitch them number 3 2016
donation list this is a word document
with a list of all donations by date
place and amount at the end of the year
you just add up the amount for the rest
of my files I do the exact same thing
number 4 is the 2016 medical list number
5 2016 Tara table mileage number 6 2016
medical mileage every time you drive
related to charity and medical it takes
just a minute to put the date place and
mileage on the document much easier
instead of trying to remember every
place you've been all year long number 7
when w-2s and 1099s
come in I scan and place them into actly
main folders number 8 the last one is my
property tax receipt taking a few
minutes to scan and document throughout
the years makes tax time much easier as
for receipts that you do not need for
tax purposes throw them away
when is the last time you needed to look
at the water bill or the grocery seat
pitch them
on the off-chance you actually need a
receipt you can call the water company
and ask for it alright Joe thanks again
to Johann Hari for joining us today
check out both of his books lost
connections and chasing The Scream you
can find those wherever you get books or
at his website Johann Hari comm he also
has a bunch of free resources over there
if we're real real quick 4 right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists I
teach a writing class
it's called how to write better you can
check it out at how to write better org
I've had hundreds of writing students
improve their writing whether you're
trying to write better tweets or
business emails or blog posts or you
want to write your first book or your
next book I can help you out with that
I think the rising tide lifts all boats
oh im gonna give you some some tips some
tricks some tactics some habits that
will help you improve your writing head
on over to how to write better dot-org
for details if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1
9 7 8 3 9 or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm will never send you
spam but we will send you our simple
Sunday emails as well for added value
this week let's listen to a song from
Saint John's new album hears call me
after you hear this and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus